I've titled this why socialism isn't
sexy okay so there's a uh a stat out
there more stats uh or a report that
attractiveness is associated with the
belief that economic success is
dependent on individual effort rather
than external circumstances okay so let
me say that again attractiveness is
associated with the belief that economic
success is dependent on individual
effort what you do rather than external
circumstances AKA what's going on around
the world around you AKA making up
excuses so uh here are some of the
details of this story and we'll open it
up for um
the panel So
Physical attractiveness is associated
with higher wages better jobs and even
higher cognitive outcomes okay
attractive individuals are more likely
to attribute economic success to
individual effort like we talked about
as opposed to the external circumstances
now these researchers have said that
earning more money Attractive people
become less favorable towards socialism
and more favorable towards capitalism
you know the redistribution of wealth
are not so much into that so you know my
whole thing is I understand this if
there's anything that I hate are
complainers victim mentality you know
excuse makers oh it wasn't my fault oh
like me yo my bad like even when she
called me out like hey about the women I
was like that's me that's on me right
there I'll do better there's so many I
feel like especially I mean not to get
too political right here and this would
is there's a lot of people you know Pat
talks about the doers and the
complainers and for so long the doers
didn't have a microphone they were too
busy doing yeah now with social media
all these complainers out there let's
just use AOC as an example it's not fair
this and that oh my God like
complainers now have a a megaphone so
you guys are all very successful this
isn't a political conversation I don't
care if you're left right up down green
purple but
um you must have like what what do you
owe to your success let's just start
with you Jed um a lot of it has to do
with
you know your ability to get out there
and do your thing an individual effort
right right so
um the victim mentality like talked
about is very unattractive what
characteristics do you owe your success
to so I think I believed in myself I
really did I remember telling my friend
like I was I was a teacher I was a
school teacher and I was just you know
regular girl in New York City making not
a great salary and I remember turning on
The View one day and saying I was on
film my friend Lauren and I said yeah I
think I think I'm gonna do that next and
she laughed and I said yeah I think
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do
television I'm gonna get into that I
just really felt like I was good at it I
believed in myself I was motivated I was
confident and I think that that's
attractive to people you know you
started this with attractiveness
Attractive people tend to be confident
you know they're not looking for you to
do for them they're looking to do for
themselves attractive confident belief
in yourself personal responsibility if I
screw up it's on me it's not your fault
I think that's all attractive and I
think you know the media business for me
was full of I mean look I just told the
story about The View I'd like have I'm
riding high on this wave I have this
amazing job big big ass paycheck two
days later I'm like oh I guess I'll just
sit home and file my nails for the next
six months you know and with media you
don't know where the next Shop's gonna
be you don't know if you're going to get
employed again you don't know when
that's coming it's like a constant
constant Hustle but I think that
believing in yourself putting your best
foot forward and you know knowing that
your success is in large part dependent
upon what you do and what you bring to
the table that's not only attractive but
that is necessary for you to be
successful in any industry I mean
anybody who's been successful will say I
pounded the pavement like unless your
dad handed you a business or you know
you were born with a silver spoon people
have had to really work hard to get
where they are that's admirable it's
attractive and it's not that victim
dependent what are you gonna do for me
no one wants that even you were saying
before you know guys don't aren't aren't
focused on what a woman makes in terms
of a salary you may not be focused on
the numbers but you'll find a woman
who's confident who really goes for
something who's passionate that will be
appealing to you that energy will
radiate through a room before someone
who's saying oh hey Adam um what are you
gonna get me for Christmas I mean that
that gets real old real fast no believe
me I know so
Shawnee would you like to go next what
do you attribute that your success to
and again you're also in media yeah I've
seen you on TV local news
um you'd like to ask two questions at a
time so I'll ask the answer the first
one and the second one because I do a
trivia
you want to make sure that I answer both
so I asked one question what do you
tribute yourself so the first one is the
first question would I attribute to my
success would be resilience I find
myself to be a very resilient person
um I know how to respond to a a lot of
various situations and I'm resilient
um yeah I'm resilient the other question
right when we look at and we say we we
say people are complainers and you know
things like that uh
oftentimes I do believe that people who
we would consider complainers
um they may have some different economic
uh barriers that some of us do not have
so it's very difficult especially for me
as a woman of color not to even speak of
um the disparity of opportunities
um that are given to you when you're
just in a different demographic when you
are educated in a different neighborhood
when you attend a different College when
your friends are different when you know
those those those things also play a
role in the barriers not that you cannot
overcome those barriers because I do
consider myself to be resilient but
those factors are present so I don't
always necessarily consider you to be a
complainer but I will say these are your
set of resistant points no matter what
they may be whether they're educational
economical physical this is this is what
you have to overcome to experience
achievement so I don't always just say
hey you're complaining but it's like
what are you complaining about you know
you know did you grow up in a poverty
stricken neighborhood where you know
educational resources were not in
abundance to you so what it would have
taken for you to be able to pass the SAT
to get into a college or university is
different did your parents have money
for you to go to school you know what
what was that equation like for you what
did you have to overcome to you know get
to that achievement so yeah I I number
one you are resilient so respect to that
to your second point I hear you not
everyone you know everyone starts at
different places but I also tend to
agree with you know nobody cares work
harder we are in America here it's not
like you know you don't have this is
still the land of opportunity some
people I've seen that thing where the
guy says take two steps forward you know
if you are raised in uh your parents are
married two people step forward take two
steps forward if you were raised in a
good neighborhood and then there's a lot
of people and quite candidly a lot of
them were people of color blacks Latinos
what have you that were further back yes
and then there were some white people
that were further up I get it okay but
at the end of the day
it's still you're you got to start with
where you're at yes I I totally agree
with that argument that you do have to
work with the circumstances in which you
were given what what it is at your delt
button the only thing the sensitivity
that I have is that I will not
necessarily see you as a complainer just
because there's a empathic part of
myself that might understand that
resilience one of the things that I have
to be really really resilient about is
right around covet I got into a really
really bad car accident it was like
really really bad I had like a whole
bunch of PTSD was really really crazy
and that was the first time that I had
had like any type of restriction on my
mental health right where you know this
PTSD was running so rampant in my body
that I was experiencing anxiety at very
very high levels so what it took for me
to remain grounded to show up for my
children you understand what I'm saying
to be present for them to cook for them
every day while managing my business you
know while going through a divorce all
of this was a lot right
um so it took a different level of
Shawnee to be able to respond to that
and for it not to take me out so that is
one of the many scenarios that has made
me very empathetic to you know what are
your challenges in terms of before I
will look at you and say that you are a
complainer you know what are what are
some of those things now did I have to
overcome that and not be able to use
that to create some economic limitations
for my children yes no I cannot use it
as an excuse but I don't see you as a
complainer I do need to you know you
know move through that and I was able to
afford therapy you understand I was able
to sit in the presence of of a
psychiatrist and you know see what my
levels were and decide no I don't want
any medication for this because of my
intelligence of my economic um you know
capability but I am fully aware that
many people don't have access to those
resources to get any support in some of
those very strenuous
um scenarios especially while going
through a divorce you know so it's very
she brings up a really great Point by
the way that a lot of people often talk
about white privilege and what they
really should be talking about is green
privilege Financial privilege because it
really does you can say work hard or
work harder but I think it would help
everybody to acknowledge that if you
come out of a family where you have you
know a lot of money in your family in a
big old house and you don't have debt
coming out of college you're not nearly
as exhausted as somebody who's been
doing that fight since like teenage
years that Financial fight it doesn't
get so it has it doesn't it doesn't give
you a pass you do have to work harder
you can make it to the top you can be
the CEO this is America land of
opportunity but it's a very different
journey and a much harder one yeah well
I don't want to be the stat guy but I
believe that 80 of millionaires are
first generation millionaires yeah okay
so like you can do it yeah and sometimes
that is the fuel right not having them
sometimes and then sometimes when you
get to those guys after having to use
that as their fuels they're different to
parent they're different to Coal exists
with because they've had to shut down so
many parts of themselves to get there so
I'm not I'm with you you can't you yeah
this guy right here is a first
generation millionaire he's killed it
awesome so you know you didn't raise
with a silver spoon in Michigan right
nope so what do you owe your success to
Pure untethered unbridled unmatched
burning [ __ ] desire full stop desire
to be rich successful what wasn't good
so um as a kid
um I thought it was I'm trying to be
rich one day but what I really wanted
was access so I could see television I
could see movies I could see magazines I
want that I want that I want to go there
I want to go there I want to be able to
do what everyone what the world has to
offer right so you see it all who the
[ __ ] does that oh someone is Rich okay
how do you get money I can't sing Can't
Dance Can't rhyme can't hack can't play
this [ __ ] not gonna do anything illegal
Sports it is so played college baseball
while playing college baseball got
introduced to entrepreneurship why the
[ __ ] they never taught the word
entrepreneurship K through 12 14 000
hours of school not counting detention I
don't know word never came up once so I
learned entrepreneurship 18 I said this
is over there's no I'm gonna be I'm
gonna kill this and that was it so
millionaire number 25 deck of a
millionaire by 30 and it was all because
I had always had the drive to be able to
have
freedom freedom is what I said access
the word of has freedom freedom to go
people are like well I'm free of a
backpack [ __ ] that I want a helicopter
to pick me up when I'm done I don't you
know like I want to shower what are you
talking about yeah I get it you're free
you're running to the Jungle sure I want
to do that trip too but at the end I
want to like at least go get a shower in
a nice hotel you know
um so freedom is is the word and
um I just went through the check boxes
of a middle class family and we were all
four of my grandparents same Factory dad
same Factory uncles Brothers all worked
there at some point so
um I just found the off ramp finally I
got lucky to find entrepreneurship at
18. so you know when somebody says hey
yeah you can climb it all the way to CEO
that's not what entrepreneurship is you
[ __ ] start as the CEO it's not climb
it's start at top down right that's the
the real American dream is not climbing
the corporate ladder the real American
dream is starting the corporate ladder
and and you know when I
I'm super ultra sensitive
um to everyone's position and argument
always I I have a lot of um
emotional intelligence and try to listen
to both sides but it only takes one
story of somebody of the worst of worse
circumstances of any person who doesn't
look like me to come from another
country as an immigrant and will [ __ ]
wipe out and own everyone else's [ __ ]
and be like you see that what you were
crying about what you didn't get for the
last 30 years this dude walked into your
country this lady walked in your country
and owns the building you live in right
it's like that's the American dream yeah
I I I'm always mesmerized to see how
much immigrants love America they value
the opportunity you have these fifth
generation kids that the parents have
been here forever and they're screaming
socialism it's like go move to Venezuela
buddy let me know how that works out so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]